we have a huge development in the case
of a California man we've been following
he is now free after being cleared of a
murder that he did not commit Ricky
Davis spoke exclusively to CBS News just
after he was released from prison
yesterday he spent nearly 15 years
behind bars prosecutors use DNA evidence
to name a new suspect Michael Green is
now in custody for the stabbing death of
Jayne Hilton in 1985 Mulaney has been
following this story mola this has been
a long time coming
oh yeah jury can probably felt a lot
longer for Davis you know he's been
working with a group called the Northern
California Innocence Project for nearly
a decade he has always maintained his
innocence in this brutal murder and now
he has a chance to create a new life for
himself after nearly 15 years behind
bars Ricky Davis walked into the arms of
his family Thursday vindicated and
grateful I'm just glad to be out I'm
setting everything behind me his first
request grabbing pizza with his loved
ones and the legal team that helped
exonerate it got this right angels are
and there they came into my life when I
really needed them more than anything in
the world
I've known Ricky for almost ten years
working on his case he's seen me through
two children and in 2005 Davis was
sentenced to 16 years to life for the
murder of 54 year old Jayne Hilton she
was found stabbed 29 times inside the
home she shared with her teenage
daughter Davis and Davis then girlfriend
he always maintained he was not guilty
but it was only through advanced DNA
testing that a judge reopened the case
Sacramento District Attorney Anne Marie
Schubert's office made the DNA link
without investigative genetic genealogy
we would not be here today new more
sophisticated tests found male DNA on
the victims nightgown and under her
fingernails
that was not Davis's the team used that
DNA and genealogical websites to build a
family tree leading them to a new
suspect 51 year old Michael Greene who's
now in police custody authorities say he
was one of three
teenagers who were with the victim's
daughter on the night of the murder
the daughter is not considered a suspect
and helped identify green as for Davis
he says he's not dwelling on the time
he's lost rather on the time he's gay I
missed so many things I can't even tell
you I've forgotten more things than I
even remember yeah I missed this
beautiful country yeah I mean I've
missed the trees I missed everything
miss fresh air you can never make up for
it I realized that you just pick up the
pieces and move forward and make the
best of what's left now this is only the
second time in US history that this type
of DNA technique has been used to not
only free a man but to implicate another
man and we've reached out to the
Eldorado County DA's office for comment
from Michael Greene the newly implicated
man or his attorney Tony but we haven't
heard back
it makes me wonder what would happen if
everybody was tested all the incredible
story bola thank you very much